hello i'm claudia doram i'm a professor
of theoretical physics
at imperial college london what i do is
really try to understand
the universe around us everything around
us nature around us
i i like to understand why the universe
is the way it is at the moment hai
has evolved towards its current state
where it's gonna where it's headed
towards and one of the questions i'm
particularly interested in
at the moment is to understand what is
making in the universe and why
the universe is behaving the way it is
at the moment
and whether the laws of nature that we
use to describe
how the universe is evolving and what is
made out of
are always the correct ones or whether
there's some sign of new physics to be
explored
i think we know that gravity is what
makes things fall to the surface of the
earth
but it's much more than that gravity is
what
was responsible for making the earth and
the solar system
and the galaxy and the clusters of
galaxies and the whole universe
in the first place if gravity wasn't
present
there wouldn't be any clustering of
elements the universe wouldn't have
evolved
to the state it is today actually if
gravity wasn't present the universe
would be a
very dense and very hot place
where no life could ever exist it would
just be a plasma of fundamental
particles so gravity is really the law
that made everything happen it's it's
the law that made the whole universe
being able to evolve
to grow bigger to grow cooler to have
structures and planets get formed but
it's also
and more fundamentally the the laws that
describes the
very nature of space and times
themselves
so it's so fundamental in our
understanding of everything
that we really need to understand
gravity to an extreme precision
to be able to understand how the
universe is evolving
and how it has got to the state it is
today
we think of two objects for instance the
how the earth
feels the gravitational attraction from
the sun and
in einstein's theory of general
relativity we can think of the
sun creating curvature in space-time
and then the earth is moving in that
curvature but still in unsung theory and
relativity associated with quantum field
theory
we can think of it more at the
fundamental level
as a continuous exchange of virtual
particles between the earth
and the sun and this continuous exchange
between the two is really
one way to think of the gravitational
force
and that's very useful if you want to
think of how a different gravity could
be because you can ask whether this
continuous exchange of fundamental
particles
the graviton particles whether they
could be massive
instead of being massless and so at
short distances this
wouldn't affect the way the earth sees
the gravity from the sun and how the
earth orbits around the
sun but if you want to think of how the
universe on
very large distances is behaving then
the
mass of the fundamental graviton
particle could have
a fundamental implication so we need to
have alternatives we have to need to
have
theories where we have small
modifications
of einstein's theoretical relativity so
we can compare
various alternatives competitors and see
what nature decides to be described by
nature will decide we we won't we just
provide different models and then we let
experiment we let
observations tell us which one is a the
best fit
you